رحلات الطيران في موسم الاصابه بنزلات
البرد والانفلونزا يمكن ان تكون بؤره
لانتقال العدوى
شانها ان تجنبك المرض خلال رحله الطيران
تتمثل في الحفاظ على منافذ التهويه
العلويه فوق راسك مفتوحه وتبرد
تبرد بالطريق الطائرات لديها واحد من اكثر
انظمه انظمه التهويه التطورا في العالم
فهو افضل قليلا من معظم غرف العمليات
والمستشفيات في جميع انحاء العالم وبحسب
الخبراء فان الحفاظ على المنافذ مفتوحه
يمكن ان يساعدك على تجنب الاتصال بعد
الجراثيم والفيروسات ويقلل من خطر اصابتك
بالمرض الى النصف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات